حسنًا حسنًا، في الأساس أعتقد أنه يتعين علينا أن
ننتظر ونرى كيف
يستجيب الحويون لقد رأينا أه بيان
من عبد مالك آلوي أه أه أنهم
سوف ينتقمون من أه هذه أه هذه
الهجمات أه ولذا سنذهب إلى  علينا أن
ننتظر ونرى كيف
سيظهر ذلك أه سنرى أيضًا بالطبع
ما هو مدى تحرك الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة أه
هل هذا أه مجرد
استجابة محدودة أو ما إذا
كانوا يتوقعون أن هذا
سيستمر لذلك  إنه آه، الوقت مبكر الآن آه،
سيتعين علينا الانتظار لنرى ما هو
آه النطاق الكامل
للردود المختلفة بشكل جيد وأعتقد أن
الهوتي توقع تمامًا أن الولايات المتحدة آه
ستتصرف كما فعلنا'  لقد قلنا أننا كنا
سنذهب خلال الأيام الماضية
لذا أه هذا لا يمكن أن يكون مفاجأة
للجذابات
أه وأه أعتقد أنهم قد
أعدوا أنفسهم بشكل أساسي بأفضل ما في وسعهم أه
أه للرد
والانتقام  لذا أه لذا أعتقد أن
كل هذا يتم بطرق يمكن
التنبؤ بها للغاية، لا أعتقد
أن الأمر على العكس تمامًا، أعتقد أن أه بالنسبة لإدارة بايدن آه، كما تعلم أنهم
كانوا واضحين جدًا في أن الشيء الوحيد الذي
فعلوه'  كنت أريد أن أرى حدوث ذلك كان
توسيع هذا الصراع خارج
غزة وهكذا أه لدرجة أن
الولايات المتحدة الآن متورطة
عسكريا أه هذه أه هذه
الهجمات في اليمن أه عكس
ما أرادت إدارة بايدن
أن يحدث أه تماما  ليس هناك أه أه
ليس هناك انتخابات أه ميزة
لإدارة بايدن رؤية هذه
التطورات لنا أه يستجيب أه
الوضع الذي يواجهونه
لا يريدون أه رؤية هذه أه هذه
الأشياء يحذرون الحوثيين من
الاستمرار  اه لكن اه لكنهم شعروا بالحاجة
للرد اه كما لديهم سواء كان
ذلك صحيحا أم لا هو
سؤال آخر ولكن حسنا أنا لقد رأينا
ما قاله عبد الملك علوي
وأه وأعتقد أننا سنرى هل أه
سواء  هناك بعض التغيير في
تكتيكات الحوتي أم لا
ونأمل إذا هدأ الوضع
ستكون نهاية الأمر أه لكن
إذا
رفع الهويس أه أه مستوى
هجماتهم فمن المحتمل أه سنرى
المزيد منا أه و  انتقام الحلفاء
أه لذا أه حقًا أه
سننتظر ونرى كيف يستجيب الحويون
لأه لهذا
الموقف